OUR REACH TO DO THIS.
>> RAMON AND LISA, TWO OF MY
FAVORITE FIGHTERS.
>> WE ARE TAKING AMERICA 31
DAYS. ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING BLOCKS IN OUR COUNTRY.
LATINOS ARE LEAVING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN. IT IS SO
BAD THAT THE MSNBC ARE TALKING
ABOUT IT.
>> WE HAVE FORGOTTEN OUR
COUNTRY AND HARD WORK.
>> NOW, HE'S ALSO A REPUBLICAN
AND MOST CONCERNED OF
IMMIGRATION AND BEEFING UP
BORDER SECURITY.
>> WHAT ARE THE CONCERNS THAT
YOU HAVE ABOUT IMMIGRATION?
>> WE DON'T FEEL SAFE ANYMORE.
>> JOINING ME NOW IS REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSWOMAN MAYA FLORES WHO'S
RUNNING FOR REELECTION IN
TEXAS. CONGRESSWOMAN, WELCOME.
THERE IS A NEW POLL THAT SHOWS
40% OF INDEPENDENT LATINO
VOTERS ARE STILL UNDECIDED
AHEAD OF MIDTERMS. IS IT ENOUGH
TO KEEP POUNDING THE PAVEMENT
ON THE ECONOMY AND CRIME, THE
BORDER OR IS THERE SOMETHING
ELSE YOU COULD BE DOING TO SWAY
THEM? OUR FAMILY AND CULTURE
VALUES, THE LAST COMPONENT
NEEDS TO BE DRIVEN HOME. MAYA,
I FOLLOWED YOU ON TWITTER AND I
SAW A TWEET THAT YOU PUT UP,
YOU SAID, PEOPLE, STOP TAKING
YOUR CHILDREN TO DRAG SHOWS,
TAKE THEM TO CHURCH. WELL,
THAT'S AUTHENTICALLY SPANISH
THING TO SAY. IS THAT THE
MISSING COMPONENT? IS THAT THE
BIG DISCONNECT THAT DEMOCRATS
ARE MISSING AND THE CULTURAL
AND RELIGIOUS AND VALUES OF
HISPANICS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY WALK AWAY FROM THE
HISPANIC COMMUNITY TO CATER TO
THE FAR-LEFT THAT'S ANTIGOD AND
ANTIFAMILY AND THAT'S WHO WE
ARE IN SOUTH TEXAS. WE ARE ALL
ABOUT GOD AND HARD WORK. THEY
WALKED AWAY FROM THAT. WE CARE
ABOUT BORDER SECURITY. WE CARE
ABOUT THE ECONOMY AND INFLATION
AND THE KITCHEN TABLE ISSUES
THAT MATTER TO EVERYDAY
AMERICANS. THEY NEED TO STOP
SEEING US JUST AS HISPANICS, WE
ARE PROUD AMERICANS AND WE ARE
IMPORTANT HERE IN SOUTH TEXAS.
WE DIDN'T HAVE A VOICE BEFORE
MY ELECTION BUT IT IS ENOUGH
AND WE FIND FINALLY DO HAVE A
VOICE IN WASHINGTON.
>> YES, WE ARE NOT BREAKFAST
TACOS.
>> THE DEMS ARE FREDDING OVER
THESE POLLS. I HEAR THEM TALK
ABOUT WE NEED TO SHOW UP OR WE
NEED TO STOP SAYING LATIN-EX.
ARE THE POLICIES IS WHAT
REPELLING HISPANIC VOTERS AT
THIS POINT IN TIME?
>> ABSOLUTELY. THEY WANT TO
TALK ABOUT ANYTHING OTHER THAN
THEIR RECORD. DO YOU BLAME
THEM? I DON'T. I CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT TALK ABOUT MY
FAILERS AS AN ELECT ELECT
ACTIVITY WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION. WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT MATTER TO
THE VOTERS. YOU KNOW THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THOUGHT WE ARE
SINGLE ISSUE VOTERS. WE ARE
NOT. WE CARE ABOUT INFLATION
AND THE ECONOMY. WE CARE ABOUT
CRIME AND WE CARE ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE EDUCATING OF
OUR CHILDREN AND WE HAD ENOUGH.
WE PUT OUR FOOT DOWN, WE ARE
NOT GOING TO SIT IN THE
SIDELINES, WE ARE IN THE FIGHT
AND WE ARE READY TO TAKE OUR
COUNTRY BACK AND GET TO WORK ON
NOVEMBER 8TH. WE ARE GOING TO
WIN BIG AND WE ARE EXCITED.
>> MAYRA, OUR LAST GUEST TALKED
ABOUT WHAT'S AT THE HEART OF
THIS ECONOMY AND THE PROBLEMS
WE ARE FACING AND SO MANY OF IT
IS THE GREEN NEW DEAL WHICH
THEY INJECTED INTO ALL THESE
DIFFERENT BILLS WHETHER IT IS
THE TRANSPORTATION BILL OR THE
FAKE INFLATION REDUCTION BILL.
THESE ENERGY POLICIES DEPRIVING
US TO BE ENERGY INDEPENDENT IS
KILLING AMERICANS IN SO MANY
WAYS. IT IS KILLING THIS
ECONOMY. WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE
TO THAT? WHY DO YOU THINK
DEMOCRATS CARE MORE ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, THE OCEAN BEING 1% COOLER
THAN THEY CARE ABOUT WHETHER
KIDS EAT OR PARENTS PUT GAS IN
THEIR CAR TO GO TO WORK OR
SENIORS HEAT THEIR HOMES.
>> THEY ONLY CARE ABOUT
THEMSELVES AND THEIR POLITICAL
PARTY. THE PEOPLE HERE IN TEXAS
ARE STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW TO PAY
THEIR UTILITIES. I GET CALLS
EVERYDAY BECAUSE THEIR UTILITY
BILLS HAVE TRIPLED AND DOUBLED.
PEOPLE ARE PAYING $900. MANY
PEOPLE ARE PAYING $3,000 AS
WELL FOR THEIR BILL. THIS IS
ALL BECAUSE OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND THEIR
POLICIES. GONZALEZ SUPPORTED
THOSE SAME POLICIES.
>> BOTH OF Y